speaking of sort of the Hollywood style
of doing things most people right at
starbucks I know me I like to write in
the car um not while I'm doing not while
you're driving yes it's a curtsy very
very thoughtful yes where do you find
your best work is done well this sounds
crazy but um there's a bar in Hollywood
that it's called the village idiot that
I used to work at back in the day and I
just find it terribly comfortable to go
there and have a couple of cocktails and
I get so much work down there obviously
I work at home in the mornings with
coffee I work at night you know I work
you know wherever I can I always have my
computer with me to stop and set up shop
but I get the most work done with vodka
and club soda at that bar so I don't
have now it's become kind of a that's
something that I have to do you know too
if I'm blocked I'll go there for a
little while and yeah it's it's great
it's kind of like my good luck charm
that's fascinating because you think so
many people's like I've got to get the
desk I've gotta get very office and set
it up and ok now I'm writing here we go
so what is it about that environment
that just like stimulates your mind so
that you're able to I honestly don't
know i think it's the fact that um there
are built-in distractions you know that
they come like you know you write for
two minutes straighten somebody says
something to you and you stop above a
bus and then you go back to it I don't
know I really don't but but i like it
intends to work for me it's when it's
all silent around that's when I have a
hard time focusing you know and it's
like in the house with the coffee and
the you know maybe some music on just
like all I want to do is check my email
right now yeah exactly exactly but you
don't want to be at a bar at a computer
tweeting you know that that's lamer than
writing they're checking in right
exactly um where are you getting ideas
for these characters remain based on
strangers you see walking down the
street where you go oh I bet you there
life is like this and you have this
whole scenario for them yeah interesting
I um mostly it's people that i know its
behavior that I've seen and i really
like stories to be grounded in reality i
like for people to be six month rule
it's very important to me that you know
somebody in the movie
that if you don't relate to my character
you relate to my best friends character
or the girl you know they have to have
touchstones for people who are in the
dating scene who are you know
experienced in this otherwise there's no
there's nothing at stake you know what I
mean you if you can't relate to the
characters then who cares that make
sense yeah and I'm curious about six
months cool so what what is the story
about it's about men dating it's about
its yes it's a it's a relationship drama
D I don't know I don't know what to call
it it's like you know you don't want to
call it a rom-com because it's not a
romantic comedies not like that it's a
it's about this this guy who I play
named Tyler watts who's a bit of a
womanizer and has all these rules on how
to avoid emotional attachment and the
six month rule is that he believes he
can get over any girl in six months and
once he knows that then he never falls
under the spell of you know love or
whatever to begin with and it's just
it's basically kind of a coming of age
story for a 35 year old boy you know
trying to become a better man um but
yeah it's about love and friendship and
sex and what happens out there you know
two single people in a metropolis kind
of cognitive world you know and I don't
know I feel like there's lots of
shortcuts and lots of tricks and lots of
rules that everybody has in their dating
life whether they want to admit it or
not you know but this guy is very
specific on what his rules of our y ver
so much I think this is a common theme
in LA I think a lot of people that come
here have trouble with intimacy and
short I'm from somewhere else and so we
don't mind coming to this big city where
everyone's anonymous so what kind of
quote research or is it people that you
knew
you talk to guys that have said like you
know I can't meet a nice girl but then
they keep doing the same right right
yeah i mean my research was literally
just you know 15 years of being single
you know in in los angeles and you know
patterns that people fall into and
missed opportunities that were missed
strictly because of you know your own
narcissism or your own fear you know and
if you like one thing that I'm very
proud about the film is it addresses a
lot of those things you know everybody's
got their hangups everybody's flawed in
this movie nobody's perfect but what's
funny is the the main characters the
most flawed of all he fully is an
antihero who hopefully goes through this
change through the movie that people can
watch it and like even if he's he bugs
you at the beginning hopefully by the
end you can understand him a little bit
more in depth and relate
you